[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya está con nosotros
en el estudio Marta bienvenida buena
mañana de lunes y por supuesto vamos a
empezar nuestra revista de prensa del
día de hoy con el tema del día que sin
duda es la escalada de las tensiones en
Ucrania y luego que krem tomara
represalias tras el ataque de dio el día
sábado en este puente el estrecho de
kerch que une de crimea con Rusia vamos
a ver cómo lo titula y cómo lo reseña la
bbc Marta así Raúl buenos días Pues
queremos destacar este fragmento de la
bbc de esta misma mañana porque mientras
hablaban o conectaban con su enviado
especial en kiev ocurría esto digamos
[Música]
bien tensionante Esto que ocurrió
precisamente una transmisión en vivo
Marta los ataques rusos también los
recoge la prensa internacional como
algeciras no recogemos una fotografía
Así es esta foto galería de al jazira
titula explosiones en el centro de kiev
y otras ciudades ucranianas las
explosiones como veníamos ya recogiendo
en el informativo se han producido en
horas de la mañana hora local antes de
que Putin se reuniera con su consejo de
seguridad al que citó ayer después de
esta escalada y de estos ataques al
puente de crimea los ataques a kiev
particularmente no se daban desde el mes
de junio y se han producido en el
distrito central que alberga oficinas
gubernamentales y parte del casco
histórico de hecho Alemania reportaba
que parte de su consulado concretamente
la oficina de visados había sido atacada
por uno de estos misiles además estos
ataques como ustedes ven detrás de mí en
las fotografías han alcanzado otras
ciudades como nipro elvif ternópil osito
mir que están en el oeste y en el centro
del país Por tanto la escalada rusa ya
bueno
se escapa de los límites del Don vas que
es donde se han producido Raúl estos
ataques las últimas semanas así es Marta
lo que vemos solo como lo estábamos
comentando antes esta consecuencia no lo
que ocurrió el día sábado este ataque al
puente que conecta Rusia con acrimea
recordemos esta península lesionada por
Rusia en el año 2014 la prensa rusa ya
publica entonces investigación de este
hecho y vamos con el primer diario así
es es el cosmos calle Prada que titula
se colocaron explosivos en rollos de
película y dice que se revelan detalles
del ataque terrorista ucraniano en el
puente de crimea ataque terrorista que
es como lo denominó el presidente
Vladimir Putin en la jornada de ayer
sostiene este artículo jefe del comité
de investigación de este atentado como
dice el kremlin sostiene que fueron los
servicios especiales ucranianos quienes
están detrás de este ataque contra el
puente de crimea que dos camiones
estuvieron involucrados y que las cargas
tenían 22 rollos de película estos
camiones llegaron presuntamente y según
Las investigaciones desde
Moscú desde Bulgaria hasta Georgia
después pasaron a Armenia y cruzaron el
puesto de control de Uber large que es
el mismo que han utilizado muchos rusos
para huir después de la movilización
para cruzar precisamente a territorio
ruso sostienen este artículo que los
explosivos fueron colocados en rollos de
película de una manera que no eran
vistos por los escáners vamos ahora con
una caricatura del Dario de Times Así es
destacamos la caricatura del mortem
morland porque Bueno pues después de
este ataque al puente de crimea se
destaca la imagen de esta ya famosa casa
de Vladimir Putin con el presidente ruso
en una esquina de la mesa caído en el
suelo que refleja un poco Esta bueno
este ataque a la soberanía rusa
perpetrada por estos agentes especiales
ucranianos que atacaron el puente de
crimea y también vemos a Los cascos de
los militares rusos tirados en el suelo
que reflejan también esta falta de
estrategia por parte de Rusia muy buena
caricatura
este lunes una bueno unas declaraciones
del presidente lukashenko de belarus que
titula lukashenko dice que belarus y
Rusia establecerán un comando militar
regional conjunto esta reunión de altos
mandos militares en belarus se ha dado
en simultáneo al consejo de seguridad de
Putin en Rusia y sostiene que lukashenko
apoyó los ataques rusos este lunes en
diversas ciudades de Ucrania y están a
favor de esta creación de un comando
militar conjunto con Moscú sin
especificar Eso sí Cuál será estas
nuevas tareas de este Comando militar
Marta rápidamente cambiamos de tema nos
vamos a Tailandia porque tras la matanza
la semana pasada una guardería que dejó
37 muertos el Primer Ministro de ese
país anunció medidas severas contra las
drogas como recojo esta noticia de la
prensa vamos a comenzar con the Guardian
el dentitula el Primer Ministro
tailandés anuncia medidas enérgicas
contra las drogas tras el ataque a la
guardería donde recordemos que murieron
37 personas el Primer Ministro
anunció medidas esencial especiales
contra los consumidores y a través
también de un de una rehabilitación
Perdón especial hacia estos consumidores
los planes de prevención de persecución
de sustancias ilegales y llevar a los
consumidores a rehabilitación están
entre las líneas de esta bueno de estas
medidas que quiere impulsar el Primer
Ministro tailandés después de la masacre
de la pasada semana en una ciudad del
noreste de Tailandia muy rápidamente
hace un artículo de opinión que dice que
perseguir a los consumidores menores no
tiene que ser el objetivo del gobierno
de Tailandia sino que hay que perseguir
las rutas y a los grandes jugadores de
esta mafia sentarlos frente a la
justicia echar a los funcionarios
corruptos que tienen la convivencia con
estos empresas de narcotráfico y cortar
las líneas de suministro de productores
de países vecinos dice este periódico
las autoridades saben que tienen que
hacer esto pero serán capaces de hacerlo
Marta Gracias mañana con más de revista
de